البدايه بنيويورك تايمز الامريكيه التي
يكشف فيها تحقيق شهادات جديده عن هجوم
حماس في السابع من اكتوبر تشير بوضوح الى
ارتباك الجيش الاسرائيلي وقله استعداده
للطوارئ وجاء في التحقيق ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي عانى من نقص الاسلحه ومن
التنظيم السيء لدرجه ان الجنود اضطر الى
التواصل عبر مجموعات واتساب والاعتماد على
منشورات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لجمع
المعلومات التي يحتاجونها لمواجهه الموقف
كما اعتقد الجيش ان حماس لن ترسل اكثر من
مجموعه صغيره اذا ما ارادت الهجوم وافتقر
الجيش لاي خطه للتصدي لهجوم واسع النطاق
وفق جنود وضباط سابقين
وحاليين يعتبر جلعاد ميري في يدعوت
احرونوت الاسرائيليه ان الهجوم على غزه
ليس خطا ولكنه في الوقت نفسه ليس حلا
الكاتب يعتقد ان اسرائيل تستطيع القضاء
على حماس والمضي قدما في تحقيق النصر ولكن
لا ينبغي عليها ان ت الخلطه بين النصر
العسكري وانهاء ما يسميه الارهاب ويضيف ان
المشكله الاساسيه تكمن في اختلال التوازن
بين اليهود والفلسطينيين وما دام هذا
الخلل قائما فحماس التاليه ستكون قاب
قوسين او
ادنى قال الكاتب سايمن تسدل في الجارديان
البريطانيه ان حربا بلا نهايه تناسب
بنيامين نتنياهو وتمكنه من تعزيز نفسه
وائتلاف ويوضح ان الحرب بلا نهايه التي
يريدها نتنياهو تعني استمراره في الحكم
لكنها في المقابل تعني قتل عدد لا يحصى من
الناس واذا نجح في تحقيق مراده فقد تكون
غزه مجرد البدايه وفق تسدل الى مجله
الايكونومست التي ذكرت ان الحرب على غزه
عمقت انقسامات المنطقه واوضحت ان
المتفائلين كانوا ياملون ان تخلق الحرب
فرصه للتوصل الى تسويه دائمه بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين لكنها بدلا من
ذلك عززت اتجاها نحو التعنت وتضيف المجله
انه من السابق لاوانه التكهن بالكيف او
حتى متى ستنتهي الحرب التي عجزت حتى الان
عن اعاده تشكيل المنطقه كما فعلت حروب
الاعوام 48 و67
و73 ختاما في مجله فورين بوليسي تحليل
يشرح تداعيات الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
على منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا يعتبر التحليل ان
المحرك الاول لتفاعل مجتمعات المنطقه مع
غزه ديني عقائدي لكون اكثر من 40% من
السكان هناك مسلمين يميلون الى التعاطف مع
الفلسطينيين واعتبرت المجله ان الحرب
اصبحت موضوع جدل سياسي داخلي في اكثر من
بلد بجنوب شرق اسيا عدا ماليزيا
واندونيسيا حيث يبدو الدعم للقضيه
الفلسطينيه اكثر
وضوحا